columbia global reports is a new book
publishing company from within a
university that is trying to get at a
big big story which is globalization
without doing it as you know we cover
globalization every day and everywhere
but instead via publishing six short
books a year each a really ambitious
work of journalism more than a magazine
could publish that gets at a significant
part of the story of globalization by
great journalists and scholars what we
have in the world today is a very great
need for more in-depth serious
journalism about global issues and we've
watched major press outlet after press
outlet pull back from the world closed
bureaus rely on stringers only go to
where the major issue is at the moment
and then leave and not return so I have
long felt that a university should take
on to some extent this mission so Lee is
is extremely interested in journalism
and that's quite rare for a university
president and he's also extremely
interested in globalization one of the
tests I want our books to meet each of
our books is there's nothing else that
quite gets at this story this is not the
14th version of the same story this is a
new story this is something that a
general reader can read and say wow I
didn't know this or I hadn't thought of
it this way what we have is this
outstanding set of small books longer
than just an essay but shorter than an
academic book on very very significant
and interesting issues our first book is
about the global financial system our
second book is about technology and it
said in China it's about a Chinese
smartphone company in the future of the
Chinese economic model our third book is
a sort of rollicking and comic tale
about little island countries that go
into the business of selling citizenship
in bulk I think the notion that Fannie
and Freddie are a global concern is
really ironic on the surface and it
almost sounds far-fetched because homes
are the most domestic asset there is
right they are literally rooted to the
ground rooted to our soil but yet over
the decades thanks in large part to
Fannie and Freddie a great percentage of
the American homeownership market has
actually come to be financed through
foreign investors so Fannie and Freddie
helped help design a system where a
saver in China can finance the purchase
of a home in in Canada but as a result
foreign investors own a lot of the
securities issued by fannie and freddie
which makes their health their solvency
of primary concern not just to american
political interest but to global
political interests what I said Nick was
I'm going to be an American
telecommunications theorists in China I
don't want to say to people this is what
it's like in China what I want to say is
here's how what's going on in China
might affect the rest of the world I
wouldn't have done a study of a you know
a local company company that only sells
phones in China what's interesting about
Xiaomi is not only are they the most
global of the telecommunications firms
that sell the consumers but they've been
aggressively global from their inception
they always meant to be global and
that's new the book is about global
citizenship which is another term for
the market for buying and selling
passports the book also talks about very
poor disenfranchised people who are
having passports bought for them by
governments who don't want to give them
citizenship of that country the two
worlds are very different on one hand
you have a business whose motto is you
can never be too rich too thin or have
too many passports on the other hand in
the case of the United Emirates which
bought passports from the Chamorro
islands for its stateless population
it's a human rights issue so there are
multiple reasons for doing this project
decline in the capacity of our
journalistic institutions to do serious
in-depth journalism a greater need of
the public for what that
offers and also a need within
universities for this kind of work that
can then refract through the scholarly
and teaching mission and I think we'll
look forward to seeing coverage of
issues that you will get no place else
in the world